[Applause]
[Music]
yep my settings and it's happening
hurry
oh
hey
hello
welcome kids to Batman Beyond colon the
holiday edition
I am Mark Bernardin hey
oh and look at I can't speak to where he
is I guess he's in the guy from UPS
house where I am I mean
little chairs I'm a throuple with that
[ __ ] lovely old couple that yeah we
are in the adventurers club together
so dirty
um I am also in a fictional Asian kids
I'm at uh let me spin your spinner
around you spin me right round baby I'm
at Jay and Silent Bob it's a secret
stash don't mind the ring life that's to
make me look younger uh right here in
beautiful downtown uh red bag New Jersey
sitting in front of a rack of my own
comics kev's comics Club look at all the
[ __ ] Comics that I've written in the
last few months alone
Comics anyway
uh I'm at Jay and Silent Bob's secret
stash
outstanding good place to be to talk
about nerd [ __ ] you're not kidding man
the Hat was uh
the choice kids because this looks a
little dark
I'm like you can't even disappearing
into the frame your second story man
doing a podcast really how are you my
friend I'm more seasonal
you should get it
how are you I'm good I'm good I'm I'm
beginning to bemoan the fact that I
don't have a hat
I feel like I should have had a Santa
hat or some [ __ ] some Garland some
tinsel some
oh very nice
oh
look at this [ __ ] seasonal as [ __ ]
wow deck the [ __ ] Halls
that's gonna grow irritating very
quickly
oh yeah um kids it's
the holiday season Christmas to some
Hanukkah to others Kwanzaa to more uh
and uh real pain in the ass for
everybody in general as they all prepare
to go scatter and see relatives and
whatnot as they're all shopping doing
their final shopping
for Christmas presents and stuff all so
that we can have a few moments uh on
Sunday that feel like wow that's that's
what life should be like man this is
your chance kids to live in your [ __ ]
Scrooged last 10 minutes of Scrooged
moment
my favorite part of Christmas is
the last 10 minutes of [ __ ] Scrooge
at this point
um I'm not a gift receiver Mark I'm more
of a giver yeah I've heard that about
you
but um I I you know so Christmas is
um
I don't I don't know I I like
I
I kind of like my whole life is one long
holiday so Christmas
you know just feels like the weekends
like when the weekends come I'm like oh
yeah this is this is everybody now has
all like I have off every day and stuff
and that's what Christmas feels like to
me it's like oh this is the day that
everybody gets to feel like I do seven
days a week
yeah I just I missed the because the
kids are are so old at this point that
the energy the dopamine release you
would get from children excited about
Christmas
um is kind of gone now there was no
standing at the top of a flight of
stairs like so [ __ ] excited about
what's happening downstairs
um that it has just become like
like you know a day of relaxation and
not a day of anticipation which is a
good energy but a different energy
um it's true I remember the days of yore
when the kid was
uh little my Malcolm just reminded me of
a
story my good friend Malcolm Ingram
sadly his mother Gloria glow we used to
do podcasts with all the time in Mont
Ontario
Toronto Ontario Mo and glow show
um his mom passed away sadly oh [ __ ] and
uh
we were uh chit-chatting back and forth
and he reminded me of this Christmas
in the past where um we were shooting
Jay and Silent Bob Strike Back are about
to shoot Jay and Silent Bob Strike Back
and we would all come to California in
November and in those days like you know
Jay was still like uh
in the throes of his uh addiction so
Malcolm was the Jay Whisperer he was the
guy who was like you know like Malcolm
we're going to pay you to sit on Jason
and make sure he don't go out and try to
score and stuff like that so you know
Malcolm
from Toronto he should have gone home
but instead he stayed with us and
um Christmas morning
um it was me Jennifer
um Byron and Gail Jones parents Harley
who was like two maybe at the time or
something like that Jason Muse
um his then girlfriend and uh I don't
know why I waved off she was lovely but
she's really part of the world anymore
um
and and Malcolm so we got a big tree and
the tree is obscenely
like overstuffed with presents because
the kid is [ __ ] two years old and so
she gets everything including like what
was called a roller coaster it was like
a wavy ramp like this and you put it on
the little cart and it just went wee it
just went down one
so kid made out like a bandit as you
would imagine Jay who was you know
struggling with his addiction he was
getting over present is over presented
as well
um as was I and Jen back and forth
the entire
like [ __ ]
all the presents this is so [ __ ]
terrible
not a single one of them was for
mountain
we sat there opening all the presents
all morning long and nobody got Malcolm
a [ __ ] thing which I was like
devastated by but Malcolm probably even
more so so Malcolm uh like you know it's
like [ __ ]
he was he was cool about it until he
[ __ ] had a few drinks later on and he
was just like I didn't even [ __ ] go
home for Christmas I didn't get a
goddamn present he goes the baby got a
[ __ ] roller coaster
um it was a bit of an open statement but
but technically true she did get a room
he was like oh the obscene wealth look
at all these dips for this kid it was
like
newborn Queen uh but yes I don't I don't
have that anymore man I mean not now
when it's like it's time to get her a
gift
um you know it's a lot more like what do
you need for your home
[Music]
[ __ ] homeowner it's no longer like
here's a baby roller coaster
although you should do that again though
here so I'm [ __ ] wrong she's got a
[ __ ] yard so it's just like here man
like it still works oh yeah I got picked
up the other day I was at a [ __ ] con
was it the con or was the last show was
the convenience tour I can't remember if
it was Hartford or if it was a Galaxy
con but
a person much taller and bigger and
stronger than me
like you know we took a picture or we
did a thing and then they like hugged me
and picked me the [ __ ] up
and such a good time like
[Music]
like I I like this gonna sound bougie
and like I don't want to come off like a
rich man but
I almost wanna find a tall giant man or
woman
or other two periodically just pick me
up and
shake me it was so [ __ ] fun no
whoever picked you up on your 50s
I mean they'll pick you up again when
you're 80 and you've got to get out of
the bed and into the wheelchair
but it's it's a long stretch I guess at
that point I'll enjoy that as well I'll
be like zaddy zaddy weed bucks needs
[Laughter]
yo Tyrone uppies
[Music]
oh my God
the idea the idea is to find like a
Hagrid [ __ ] like like one of the
blue cats in Avatar would tell you
talking about later on there are moments
in Avatar where there's like a giant
blue cat [ __ ] with a little person
and I'm like not [ __ ] literally that
would have been you know then he could
have went three and a half hours I would
have watched that [ __ ] but but just
they're interacting and I was like that
looks oddly comforting to be picked up
and held by something that giant like
remember in the first avatar where she
had Jake Sully
oh Jake's and she had she's like oh my
Jake at the end and he was Sam
Worthington and not the big blue cat and
she was like [ __ ] gigantic that's the
right relationship right there just give
me a giant ass he needed he needed more
of that in Avatar too the way of way of
the water or whatever the [ __ ] it should
have been Avatar too
[Laughter]
yeah like I feel like they missed the
boat on the new Gods movie that didn't
happen just make it [ __ ] big Barta
just picking on [ __ ] it's just
like it's just a fetish flick that's all
it is for the first [ __ ] time ever
I'm like I would watch a new Gods movie
like big Barta and a little scot-free
yeah and I'm not talking Miniature but
like clearly a foot or less yeah
and she's you know picking them up all
the time and [ __ ] throwing them under
it's like over her shoulder and [ __ ]
I mean they got the effects now they
made She-Hulk look [ __ ] huge and
round other people hell yeah
I'm saying before we talk about the big
bartification of Cinema
what it means for those of us who are
little take turnpiece we should probably
uh talk about who's uh sponsoring this
here's show man uh
somebody asked Eric Burch said I guess
Kev won't be smoking as he's in the
store or is it Edibles time I mean we'll
see the store is technically still open
mike zapcik a comic book man Mike zapson
was kind enough to be like he wants to
close the store but I was like the you
know greedy businessman in me I'm like
at Christmas like I got scrooge-like
I was like no we're staying open till 10
but um I you know if if it's slow enough
and [ __ ]
I could I could see that I think I can
get away with that I know a guy
and the person like yell at me and [ __ ]
and get me in trouble or be you know my
only answer to like a few people in this
world uh and
Carol who runs everything Carol Hammond
my my Chief Financial Officer my
business manager whatever
um Carol is the is the giant blue cat
who cradles me and keeps me [ __ ] safe
and prevents me from hurting myself
and otherwise you know she's always like
you know you don't need that slow down
stuff like that she's Jiminy Cricket
every penny I had would be long [ __ ]
gone were it not for for uh Carol so why
am I why did I bring her up
uh the people you answer to
yes thank you she's not here she went to
see she went overseas to see her kid
which is beautiful Merry Christmas doll
but like if I if I smoked and she was in
town
she'd be down here in a shot and be like
what are you doing did you you're
jeopardizing everything you built put
that out no she don't yell but she'd be
like stop she ain't here so
now Daddy's in charge
we're being a roller coaster in the
store oh look who it is kids it's Banff
man welcome Batman to the show hey Vamps
man how's it going uh your story
reminded me of a time I was out with Jay
we were making tusks and every day
before we went to set or while we had
lunch Jay and I drove to either Target
or Best Buy
and we were at Best Buy at lunch and he
was wearing like this really weird
Gilligan's Island type Gilligan hat at
the time
right and somebody stopped and they're
like are you Jay can I take a picture
with you and he took a picture
and
Jordan didn't travel for Tusk it was it
was like uh you know like the three of
us in the car every morning and uh
if I remember correctly she well she
with child is that around uh maybe she
just couldn't she had to hold down the
fort but Jay was there every day yeah so
so Jay and I were hanging out and it was
like Jay getting to hang out with his
friends again unsupervised
and uh and so
this this lady takes the picture posts
it on Instagram and not more than three
minutes later my phone rings and it's
it's Jordan she goes tell Jay to take
off that stupid [ __ ] hat click
oh fast so be careful because Carol
could be watching
she's well Jordan is the other you know
one on the other coast
is the Carol of like you don't need to
do that but she has to do it for two
people uh not just me but also her
husband who is far more wasteful and
spend Thrifty than than me it's you know
we're both kids we figured it out
um we're both kids that grew up
completely without he even more than me
I I have my parents like struggled to
put [ __ ] together I had Star Wars
figures he did not so
once life was like hey you're these
[ __ ] idiots in movies until you die
and here's some money to go along with
it well
naturally most of that money went to
like now I could buy all the things that
I never bought and it was a series of
[ __ ] toys if you ever see Jason's
like room if when he streams
it's just
[ __ ] covered
with toys like he's he has so many that
he sends him to the stash for his
private collection where he overprices
them and puts them on a shelf here and
that way if they sell he's sad but at
least he made like more money than he
ever would have and [ __ ] but he's just
using this place as storage for all this
[ __ ] toys and stuff
um
so
uh why was I talking about him God I
don't need to smoke weed I [ __ ]
smoked right before the show apparently
oh so Jordan is always like hey man
don't hey man don't to the two of us and
stuff
um nobody's here now
who can tell it's not like there's
anything flammable we shall see
um all right let's uh let's give a
sponsor here dude indeed perhaps native
Deo
yeah I'm all for it man let me pull it
up
Oh you mean our friends the good Folks
at Native indeed when it comes to
personal hygiene who's got time read
that long list of ingredients on the
back of the bottle some ingredients I
can't even pronounce
that's to be fair I can't pronounce a
lot of things
um like when I first got to Los Angeles
I called it Sepulveda Boulevard
they've got a lot March laughing at me
a guy from out of town when he
mispronounces [ __ ]
um if you're like me and you care about
what goes on your body man then guess
what it's time to try native as we talk
kids
follow along over at nativedeo.com
spelling for and feel fresh all day long
with Native uh get 20 off your first
order by going to nativedeo.com Fatman
or use the promo code Fatman all one
word at checkout that's nativedeo.com
Fatman or use the promo code Fatman at
checkout for 20 off your first order
kids it's that time of year where you
could smell like uh sugar cookies or
candy canes a bunch of edible shipment
thanks to the good Folks at natives they
don't put weirdness in it they put all
natural [ __ ] it's all natural you could
eat I've said this many times let's say
you're like in a plane that's going over
the Andes and it goes down and you're
like those poor kids and survive or
Alive depending on what you saw which
movie Yellow Jackets I survived when I
was a kid alive
in the 90s and now Yellow Jackets good
point well that's a way more current
reference hey kids imagine you're in
yellow
season two and uh and like the plane
goes down and [ __ ] and they're eating
berries in the in the woods not you
you're eating your native because it's
made all natural ingredients don't
that's the only situation under which
maybe think about eating it but I'm just
saying you can't do that with some other
roll on or spray can
think about those yellow jackets moments
in life nobody prepared for that oh
other deodorants are prepared to help
you not sweat but are they prepared to
save your life when the plane goes down
the woods and you go feral with a bunch
of girls like yourself
for one guy maybe two another couple
guys there's a couple guys in the show
when's season two anyway
enough about them back to Native kids
Mark tell them what they need to know
native deodorant checks a lot of boxes
72-hour order protection naturally
derived ingredients and a smooth
residue-free application also offers a
variety of scents with new and limited
edition scents being released all the
time like warm cider and cinnamon
cashmere and Rain toasted marshmallow
and vanilla Wildwood and cardamom
oh my God forget it and when you use
native you will smell amazing all day
long thanks to their long lasting scents
spicier woodsy clean and fresh they've
got a scent for everyone so Now's the
Time to make the switch from an
antiperspirant to Native and when you
visit their site you can discover all
their fresh scents and maybe even try
one out uh try one of their body washes
while you're at it
so smelling fresh smelling fresh clean
smell and feel fresh all day long with
Native get 20 off your first order by
going to nativedeo.com Fatman or use
promo code Fatman all one word at
checkout that's nativedeo.com Fatman or
use promo code Fatman at checkout for 20
off your first order
uh kids we thank the good Folks at
Native uh not just for tonight but all
year long these native folks I God
knoweth why
leaving us in our show
um you know maybe it's because every
week I'm like I use it or maybe because
they see actual real transactional you
know Justice and in being our sponsor
but for whatever reason kids
we love the good Folks at Native as much
as you can loves people you've never met
I never met these people but I [ __ ]
love them they make this show possible
that and a grant from the Helena Ruben
stock and viewers like you and who gets
a tote bag
I don't know you want a tote bag come to
Jay and Silent Bob's Secret Sauce kids
uh those who came in late that's where I
am look at this [ __ ]
we're doing our comic book show out of
comic book store
one that was uh on TV well not this
Incarnation but the previous incarnation
of the stash very famous Mark show
called uh Comic Book Men perhaps you've
heard of it
indeed I I saw it from afar
um all right
we got [ __ ] to do we do we'll do a
little news and then we gotta do the
other AD as well kids I'm gonna put it
on Front Street with you
um you know fat man beyond is a show
that can tend to run long sometime not
tonight because Batman has a thing he's
got to do and stuff but uh when it does
and you have multiple sponsors and the
other sponsors wind up happening like
two hours after the show begins uh those
sponsors are justified in being like
what the [ __ ] or just the [ __ ] so we'll
be front loading our ads going forward
yeah so we'll do a Sprinkle of news then
we'll get into the big topic of today
which is uh talking about Avatar wave
the water
um and then we'll come back to q a but
we'll we'll hit add number two I'm
pretty in pretty short order
um so we'll have uh Native good Folks at
native art sponsor right now as you know
another one coming up
uh but before we even go there man
there's a third sponsor what is it it's
me you that's damn right I'm selling
something uh we got uh a New Year's Eve
show and it's just me if you've ever
wanted me to use my mouth all over you
New Year's Eve is the time uh December
31st kids 10 o'clock at smodcast Castle
Cinemas I'm doing a New Year's evening
with Kevin Smith standing up there and
chit chatting uh and just giving you
oral right till 2023 man until next year
that's how that's how prolific I am at
it pragmatic but uh come on out Man
tickets it's mod
castlecinemas.com uh we've been having a
good time at spawn Castle Cinemas uh
Mark the other night I had a screening
well you know we multiplexed so a bunch
of movies play there one of them is a
motion picture called Avatar
I I was like oh I'm gonna watch it but I
might as well use this as a marketing
opportunity
um so I was like hey man I'm gonna watch
Avatar on Sunday who wants to watch it
with me I'll q a afterwards even though
I had nothing to do with the movie and
um I got 35 people
can we watch a movie with you I think 34
of them were coming regardless and they
were confused while I was there no it
was um it was really lovely and then
afterwards I got up and Q a and you know
I wasn't like talking for Jim Cameron
but I was just about the facts that I
knew and [ __ ] like that
um and as a representative of like
Hollywood I got some questions like why
is [ __ ] so expensive I'm like oh my God
I'm so glad you asked and I could
um but it was uh it was it was fun so I
built a schedule that's what I did the
other day for the first six months of
2023. uh including uh clerks open all
night the clerks want a clerk I ain't
calling it one clerks clerks two and
clerks three Marathon were doing it's
January 21st kids set the date save the
date as they say in the wedding
Community but I built the schedule
including
this is where it becomes relevant to our
interests right here
uh The Ides of Mark
on the schedule let me pull it up and I
can actually give you [ __ ] legit
dates man I love dates dates are awesome
I I hit up Mark and I was like man
what's
when can you do and what can you do and
he gave it to me and
now I can't find it where the [ __ ] are
you
just about
smart Castle
sorry I'm one of those people that talks
out loud when he does a thing
uh okay in
March now some people are going to be
like when's Zack Snyder coming I didn't
I haven't booked that because I gotta
wait until he tells me when he's coming
but he said so we'll be putting those
dates in these dates are you know all
the schedule I built is based on the
stuff I know for a fact is coming and
when blah blah blah
um as other folks like the russos are
like Hey we're ready those things will
get slotted in naturally I'll tell
people but if you're looking for the
odds of Mark kids which is uh Mark
Bernard programming his own Festival it
begins of course on the Ides of March
5th March 15th with a screening of Dune
David
he was very specific he's like not the
not the new Dune he's going though I
liked it he's got classic Dune of course
uh then uh we'll do q a afterwards then
uh or Mark will do q a afterwards and
ask some questions
why do you love this movie so much uh on
the 16th The Ides of Mark continues with
Attack the Block
with Mark Bernardin hell yeah kids
um then on the 17th
um at 8pm the uh Ides of Mark continues
with Streets of Fire
that's right we're all going to sing
along and then uh for the 18th
um there are two events the odds of Mark
is a episode of fat man beyond that
night so Batman March 18th
um we'll be doing it
from uh from uh smartcastle Cinemas and
then after that at like 10 o'clock is
the if you're around and you're into it
the merry Marvel marching my Marvel
movie Society we're doing Iron Man 2
that night
so if you want to sit in on that
um but yes my schedule is built oh my
God I
there's fun things afoot you want to
come see me and Mark
in uh in my home and native land of New
Jersey that's my castle Cinemas
foreign
they are upon us
um okay should we go into the movie or
go into the moves
um we could go into
the news
we'll save Avatar a little bit okay
um so this comes from that guy the other
guy not me man he used to be in the news
in the trenches now he makes news but
back then he covered news so he knows
how to cover it and he's covering it
right now for you welcome back uh
temporary newsman Mark Bernardin thank
you Mr Smith I appreciate the the
handily tossed
um references
um so we recorded an episode last week
and then literally like half an hour
after we went off the air James Gunn
decided I have more things to say about
what's happening at DC I know like I've
almost before we did this show I told
Mark I was like look I got James number
maybe I should text him and be like last
week we did a whole show and then all of
a sudden you announce a bunch of things
we're about to do a whole last show
anything we wanna
a heads up just that's all I want but I
don't want to like I want to text James
so badly about unrelated matters I want
to ask him like what date are you coming
to the theater with Guardians of the
Galaxy 3 but I'm afraid right now that
the whole world since he's been
announced as the head of DC like the
whole [ __ ] world's probably reach out
to him and if he sees a text from me
like my name pops up first thing he's
going to think is [ __ ] wants a
job and it's like no I don't well I do
want a job but not like at Warner Bros I
want you to come to the movie theater
uh so I got to get up the nuts too I'm
going to let things calm down because
based on the news that happened last
week and the news that continues
um you know the internet has become a
stormy sea uh for uh
um uh poor James uh but boy oh boy
like smod bless him I saw him just
sticking to his guns he's like look I
know that people are going to be mad I
know that people are you know gonna call
for my death and [ __ ] but like I I'm not
going to be moved by you know people
saying mean things we have a plan and
there'll be a period of transition but
we're gonna get there that dude is
remember remember that [ __ ] book
you're a better man than I am good din I
I would crumble Mark you saw me last
week somebody was like you should have
died from the heart attack and [ __ ]
20 minutes I was like
James Gunn is at the epicenter of far
more [ __ ] Firepower and hate than
I've ever been even with Masters of the
Universe believe it or not and what he's
a picture of Grace Under Pressure he's
just like
he's gonna you know and not in a shitty
combative way he's given real responses
to questions like news is coming out of
this like I've seen so many news pieces
from his tweets and whatnot but he is he
is brave man he's he's Brave that's they
they you know
I'm good thing they didn't pick me to do
that job the moment somebody was like
you're an [ __ ] I've been like Peter I
quit like you know what
I I will say like as I on the one hand I
find it admirable that James is as
interactive with an audience as he is
but on the other hand it's like there is
nothing to be gained by it like just
like there's probably a very good reason
why Kevin feige doesn't even have a
Twitter account like imma just go do
this [ __ ] like you'll see when you see
it right and generally people love those
movies I mean I know there are people
that are like [ __ ] mood but like
generally Marvel movies are very
favorable and even with that like if I
was Kevin feige I'd be like I'm gonna
sit online and collect my flowers and
[ __ ] because I'm doing a [ __ ] massive
story that everybody loves and even that
dude's like maybe that's how you stay
productive he's like no time for my
flowers just moving forward ever forward
there's nothing to be gained by it
um but you know it's it's good for the
news industry it's good for the hot take
industrial complex to have him just
lobbying information and occasional
grenades out into the world and so when
we wrapped last week
um he lobbed another grenade basically
saying that he was writing a new
Superman movie and in the process of
writing this new Superman movie somebody
was out of a job
um so this was the Twitter the tweets
that he sent out uh Peter Safran uh
co-head of DC Studios and I have a DC
slate ready to go which we couldn't be
more over the moon about and we'll be
and we'll be able to share some exciting
information about our first products
projects and beginning of the new year
among those on this latest Superman in
the initial initial stages our story
will be focusing on an earlier part of
Superman's life so the character will
not be played by Henry Cavill but we
just had a great meeting with Henry and
we're big fans and we talked about a
number of exciting opportunities to work
together in the future
[Music]
um
so we are I think in effect seeing you
know what I think we had assumed would
be one of a couple of possibilities
which was the end of the Snyder verse as
we know it
um oh yeah I'm sorry I was I was just
smiling at somebody in chat said I've
seen pictures of your daughter's
boyfriend you could totally still use
that roller coaster
damn
um and I'm choosing to think that means
because he looks like a kid who enjoys a
roller coaster Mark that's what I think
fair enough
um this news
um of course uh came with uh mixed
emotions I was super excited to hear the
James Gunners writing a [ __ ] Superman
film James say what you will about James
like James the hell of a writer uh you
know Scooby-Doo
uh Dawn of the Dead
um you know the Guardians movies like he
didn't even write brightburn as well
uh he executive producer said I think
his brother wrote it oh Brothers for
that matter that's some talent in that
family they know how to those guns are
loaded thank you
um but you know sad to see Henry Cavill
go just when Henry Cavill was like ah
back kids I'm not back oh my bad I'll
see you on the Witcher wait no God damn
it like
I I that I mean doesn't you just showed
up at the end of Shazam he did and then
the Black Adam you know and and he also
you know Black Adam not Shazam uh he
just showed up the end of Black Adam
yeah I mean Henry Cavill also you know
on apparently social medias where
everybody has these discussions now it
is said I will after all not be
returning to Superman after being told
by the studio to announce my return in
October prior to gun and saffron's hire
uh this news isn't the easiest but
that's life The Changing of the Guard is
something that happens I respect that
James and Peter have a universe to build
and I wish them all and I wish them and
all involved with a new universe the
best of luck and the happiest of
Fortunes
um he also shot a cameo in the flash
um but sources say that along with Gal
Gadot is Wonder Woman that Cameo is now
being cut
um giving the studios choice not to go
forward with Wonder Woman 3.
I mean really so
I mean
wow like
you got a free you already shot it you
gotta shot it you got free what could be
here last appearance might
you know
[ __ ] if people didn't like Wonder
Woman 84 it could be
you know a nice like ah well she was in
that and then she went why I mean why
would you
I mean you're getting ready for you're
ramping up a different
that's probably the thing is that at
some point you have to decide we're
going to rebuild this from jump
um and the longer you continue to put
out versions of the old team the harder
it is at some point to just make the
transition to the new team so I guess
and this is again this isn't James Gunn
saying it it is sources say
um and I personally don't know what
those sources are they are sources that
confirm this to outlets like deadline or
Hollywood Reporter or what have you we
are we're not even re-reporting it we
are reiterating the news
um but you are at some point going to
have to decide to rebuild your team and
it seems as if they've decided that now
is that time
um yeah good Lord
um well
so I guess somebody's got to do it yeah
yeah
man it takes a spine that I ain't got
to head into the internet and be like uh
I'm not gonna do what you want
[Laughter]
um but I look forward to see where it
goes seems weird
to cut those
can't I mean especially because isn't it
like a story of
multiverses and
I think so but I don't know in what
in what fashion those cameos were
presented
you know like if if it had the tenor of
this is the last time we're gonna see
these people or is it in between
Adventures we catch up with Wonder Woman
and like
you don't want to promise further story
when there isn't going to be any and so
I guess the other question is do we
reshoot those cameos
um at at Great expense to
re-contextualize them as the ending of
that particular universe or do we just
cut them and not even have that part of
the story because they can't have been
integral to the story per se if they're
just cameos
so I don't know what the answer to that
is but apparently he was paid something
like 250 000
um for that Cameo both at the end of
Black Adam and in the Flash
I mean
Flash
seems to be the hero Killer movie
[ __ ] Michael Keaton Batman didn't
make it out alive
woman didn't make it out alive
somehow Israel Miller is still sprinting
across the fish
so weird it's like like if you were
gonna pick which one of these people
should we get rid of like based on
headlines you might go like I'm a fast
guy
he seems a little dodgy instead they're
like everybody else yeah they seem a
little dodgy forgive me I uh they got
Blue Beetle coming
they do and and they seem committed to
it
um Henry Cavill on the other hand has
moved on to uh to make Warhammer 40 000
for Amazon
um based on the very popular science
fiction fantasy miniature war game
um which of which he's a adherent and
devotee like you Henry Cavill is a
fellow who will make his own PCS to to
game who will paint his own Miniatures
for for role-playing and so he is 100
down to make a series about his favorite
tabletop war game
so everything works out everything works
it all comes out in the wash
um
well
I I mean
guy was unemployed for about 30 seconds
another big job
and uh we're apparently we're gonna have
another Superman I you know I'll miss uh
Henry but
you know kids I'm a pro I've had a
couple Supermans in my lifetime
you'll have a couple more George Reeves
my [ __ ] Chris Reeves my [ __ ] Tom
Wellen
Brandon Ralph my [ __ ] Henry Cavill
who's the new who's the current guy uh
Tyler hochlin higher hocklin [ __ ]
Dean Kane
Dean [ __ ] Kane I've seen every
Superman I've seen every single man Dean
can't even I can't do the list but you
know
a pro is used to seeing a couple
different faces in the costume and stuff
so as much as I'll miss Henry it's like
well
that's that's what happens like sooner
or later there's another Superman like
there's another Batman like there's
another James Bond like there's another
Spider-Man
everything old is new again all things
must change I'm into it I mean I'm the
idea of
more DC movies I I don't think you get
away with too many reboots I mean in
comics we've seen that be diminishing
returns but they reboot their entire
universe but I think in this case
you know they may get away with it yeah
I mean it's it feels like it's the time
for it I think I I mean I know like the
internet of some portions of the
internet are mad at them but like James
Gunn riding a [ __ ] Superman script is
like
this this nation doesn't deserve that
that's a Christmas miracle right there
what a gift
um I mean the one thing that I'm that
I'm a little curious about is I'm sure
they had some meetings with other
writers
and it's like all right yeah I'll do it
I'll go up I'll go pitch my my Superman
take the James gun it's like I hope I
get it at the end of the day it's like
well who got the job the guy you pitched
to
he gave himself the job of writing
Superman which on the one hand you don't
give James Gunn that job unless you want
James Gunn to actually write and direct
some of those movies but on the other
hand it's like oh man
I thought I had a shot you didn't
Seth Martin in chat says Super Friends
the movie is what I'm looking forward to
enough of this depressing [ __ ]
oh could you imagine if [ __ ] we get
to a place where
we just call the movie Super Friends In
the Hall of Justice
remember I would play it again but
remember we played it one time and we
got thrown off [ __ ] YouTube I know
listen to it again Superman Batman and
Robin Aquaman Wonder Woman
[Laughter]
you know see everyone's like
everyone's like you go woke you go broke
and everything's woke now kids it was
woke when we were kids too
like they they started bring diversity
happened in the late 70s early 80s kids
like they started being like hey there's
a lot more than just [ __ ] white
people
spoilers
[Laughter]
um so I've seen all I've seen so many
Supermans I've seen Apache chief
I've seen attack ships on fire off the
shoulder of Orion
seeing tears and rain
I've seen things you people wouldn't
believe
I will also apparently get to see Donald
Glover play the Hypno Hustler
did you know this was a thing that was
going to happen
um
Donald Glover is attached a storm
producer feature said in Sony Pictures
this Spider-Man universe
playing
the Hypno Hustler who was created by
Bill mantlow
he of Rocket Raccoon feign uh a Hypno
Hustler was a product of the disco music
scene when he first appeared in uh The
Spectacular Spider-Man number 24 1978
his real name was Antoine Del soin the
leader of a band called The Mercy
killers and he used hypnosis technology
in his instruments to Rob his audiences
he regularly shows up on worst super
villains of all times lists but Glover
apparently is all about the musical
aspect of the character and the fact
that he has less Marvel Canon baggage
um
so like Childish Gambino wants to play a
sort of disco period villain in his own
Spider-Man offshoot movie
fine I'm ready give it to me
uh I'm so ready I mean all of it sounds
just so Daffy that uh that I'm here for
it Rick Jones and shackos go home Sony
you're drunk
stop it you're gonna ruin everything DJ
Kanto says this should be a musical and
he should produce the music let's go
this could be fun as [ __ ] I like that
kind of optimism you're absolutely right
yeah I mean oh my God humongous feature
Otto Matton says versus dazzler
um is she part of the Spider-Man
Universe
um she's a mutant she's a mutant so that
that has to become some inter company
Jammy Jam but not impossible make it
happen
it is uh the Atlanta Emmy winning uh
Donald uh Glover grammy-winning Childish
Gambino as the Hypno Hustler yeah I'm
here for it
that is all the news my friend that's it
that's all that's happening it was a
quick hit news day
um let's talk a little bit about uh
black Adam
um that continues to not
go get a sequel
it's it's been a like a
seems like a I see a lot of negative
stories
aimed at or about the Rock
based on Blackout he always appeared to
me as very like invulnerable
you know no there's no [ __ ] ever and no
[ __ ] would ever stick but
the the Black Adam situation there's a
story about how he was out there going
oh no it's profitable hear why and he
told deadline and apparently that wasn't
the case or whatnot yeah I mean I think
that like The Rock has always been the
kind of Teflon pitch man in that he he
could be reliably counted on to deliver
50 million people worth of Instagram
Twitter followers or whatever at
whatever thing he was making and you
know
however invested he was in it be it his
his tequila brand be it you know movies
good bad or indifferent like he would
get in he would sell it the selling was
over and he'd move on and it just feels
as if what the Black Adam of it all
there's not just he seems to have
wrapped some of his personality into
Black Adam success and or failure maybe
because it's part of the one of the
longest things he's worked on in his you
know telling of it he's been wanting to
make this move for some 15 years and he
finally did
but the feeling that he's almost trying
to Gaslight the audience into somehow
believing that a thing that wasn't a hit
was a hit that a thing that probably
won't get a sequel will the the his
double and tripling quadrupling down on
its box office fortunes you know I think
is
it's rubbing people the wrong way
you know it's like hey man like I get it
you made a movie you wanted to make and
it didn't go well
um but
move on to the next thing that's what
you do that's what you did when run
notice came out and that movie's awful
um but like it came out you sold it you
made you know ads with all the
characters in it talking about vodkas
and Gins and then you went on to make
other stuff but it's the it's the the
unwillingness to let it go you know the
rock is beginning to feel Petty and
nobody wants that guy to feel Petty
um
and it feels it's an emotional response
to his emotional response and that that
I think is what's giving people pause
um we're but we're not getting a Black
Adam too it looks like it does not seem
like we are
um the the box office receipts would not
indicate that there's room for it you
know
maybe maybe there is a plan maybe like
we don't know the totality of what James
Gunn and Peter saffron are building for
the DC Studios ongoing slate but you
know it's it's not as if it's an
undeniable box office hit that would
demand more it wasn't black panther
um nor does it feel like it's a
character that is inherently crucial to
an ongoing version that story The Way
Superman Batman or Wonder Woman are or
even Brainiac or Lex Luthor are or The
Joker Is
um he's kind of a fourth tier villain
for a character who may not get more
movies
um namely Shazam and they went a
different weight which is him Shazam was
totally never going to allow
for an angry ex-slave to be resurrected
from the past to do battle with a child
um in the Greatest American Hero version
of Shazam and so without that connective
tissue he's a bit on an island and it
does not seem like it's an island
anybody wants to visit again your
analogy of Shazam is the Greatest
American Hero is one that I have never
thought of until this moment I mean
that's that's what Zach Levi is doing
and it's working I mean it's it's the
first movie did very well I saw the
trailer for the second movie and it's
like no that looks fun
not entirely for me but I don't know how
to be a superhero is what that story is
thank you that is the last American The
Greatest American Hero
luga what's happening to me
I can't believe
myself
uma's not good for [ __ ] do what no it
isn't I mean I know
when I fall
uh but where do we start now we started
look at what's happening to me okay it
was happening to me
I can't believe it myself take it
flying away in the town
suddenly I'm up on top of the world see
I forgot the first part suddenly I'm up
on top of the world should have been
somebody else
I'm Walking on Air
I never thought I could be so free
flying away on a wing and a prayer
who could it be believe it or not
exactly
uh I feel like this is a perfect time to
do our second hat
yeah half the people tuned out with the
singing so I'm trying to sell them
something uh kids we got another sponsor
and it's an old favorite of mine all the
old faves are coming out for our holiday
show here which may not be the last show
of the year we might do another one
before it's possible yeah so don't don't
this ain't the last one it's just the
Hollywood
and when I say holiday
I mean Christmas Hanukkah Kwanzaa
whatever is there is there another
Christmas I'm missing is there is there
another Christmas well there's like
Greek christmas-ish Orthodox Christmas
what do they do
uh I think it's just more food
I want to be part of that religion yeah
I know it's fun
good night
weddings take forever but the food is
good
um tis the season for clean balls
Segway our friends at manscape are
helping you clear your driveway for safe
travels this holiday season Once Again
this is this is Pearls Before spawn this
is some of the best copywriting in the
business whoever's writing this [ __ ]
deserves a raise this is the next John
Hughes right here
um because John Hughes came from
advertising did you know that I did not
know that
he wrote a jingle very famous one I
forget which one it is it might have
been like the
you know this [ __ ] uh or [ __ ] on
aftershave or something or Gillette but
he wrote a pretty famous campaign the
best a man can get yeah something like
that or there's something about an aqua
velvet pop fizz fizz so what a relief it
is
I don't think that was his because that
predates him but it's something that big
where you're like what like this guy had
breakfast club and that like looks like
a pump feels like a sneaker
I wanna no he didn't do that
that is that is that a condom That Was
Easy Spirit it's loafers for women
um kids we ain't talk about any of that
we're talking about manscape from
stocking stuffers to white elephants
manscapes products are at the top of
every wish list grab some crop mops for
your pops for the body buffer for the
holiday lover win this year's white
elephant gift and help all the men in
your life go from eggnog to nice hog
20 off plus free shipping by going to
manscaped
m-a-n-s-c-a-p-e-d.com slash
fat man uh do it right now man save 20
off plus free shipping by going to
manscape.com Fatman that's right 20 off
with free shipping by going to
manscape.com Fatman manscape for perfect
gift that will be the holidays biggest
hit manscape takes all the hair off your
nuts so your junk looks bigger it's that
simple
perception game yes it's all about
object and permanence
forced perspective
see kids when The Horizon's on the top
when The Horizon's on the bottom it's
interesting when The Horizon's in the
middle it's boring as [ __ ] so put
smaller things in the foreground a few
dick pics to make it look bigger and
also
crop that mop you know who love manscape
the great John Ford
he didn't call it Monument Valley for
nothing
um tell them what they're getting smart
when they [ __ ] with the good Folks at
manscaped uh manscape is a One-Stop shop
for all your holiday needs they have the
perfect gift in the Platinum package 4.0
plus loads of little presents perfect
for stocking stuffers manscaped offers a
handful of their liquid formulations
shampoos body washes upstairs and
downstairs deodorant jails exfoliant
everything everything everything you
could possibly need to keep it keep it
clean and don't let your chestnuts roast
in the wrong boxers get them a pair of
manscape boxes specifically designed to
keep the area cool and provide holiday
Comfort all year round
uh dad has nasty nose hairs save his
life with a weed whacker nose and ear
hair trimmer shears 2.0 is their full
kit for the Nail Care scissors Clippers
tweezers and a file for the traveling
man there's a new preserved cologne that
brings a light Breezy woodsy feel and
gives that fresh tree scent even after
Christmas is over and if you're still
using a loofah introducing the body
buffer uh well loofahs actually hold
bacteria from dead skin but help them
throw out that disgusting old loofah and
get the body scrubber that feels
smoother but acts tougher lastly top off
that stocking with the crown jewel for
their Family Jewels the lawnmower 4.0
the electric razors Advanced Skin safe
technology is a life changer and known
for reducing Nicks and cuts on his Santa
sack manscaped is here to make holiday
shopping a blast by giving products
you'll love and make you laugh so save
20 off plus free shipping by going to
manscape.com Fatman that's right 20 off
plus free shipping by going to manscape
m-a-n-s-e-a-p-e-d.com slash Fatman for
the perfect gift that will be the
holiday's biggest hit
we thank the good Folks at manscape for
being a sponsor not just tonight but
many nights that we've done fat man
beyond especially the earliest fat man
beyond we've ever done indeed the
afternoon delight truly
afternoon Tyler hall or Tyler rehaul in
uh chat says The Edge Credit Card shave
was by John Hughes oh that he created
that campaign
okay I was hoping it was a something
more famous than that right some more
famous than that it's not my bad I set
you up for
[ __ ] big expectations and but Edge
Credit Card like a lot of people in the
60s 70s might remember that
anyway enough about [ __ ]
from P Wayne Smith says like watching
live ads in the 50s
um no those cats they had their dignity
yeah they wore suits and ties they stood
up in front of mics
I have a suit jacket you do a thermal
waffle shirt because let me tell you
something
Mr Mark Bernardin it is cold in New
Jersey
um you know I'm a man that fancies a
walk up from onion Canyon when he's Los
Angeles
um where the you know sometimes I get up
in Los Angeles like oh 50. and turn the
heat on
[ __ ] I I went hiking yesterday and
today did my four four and a half miles
each day I wore so many [ __ ] layers
so many thermals and my a big purple
[ __ ] coat and a full face mask that
made me look like you know the [ __ ]
task master and a backwards baseball cap
just to complete the look fingerless
gloves because I didn't have any gloves
but Josh Roush had fingerless gloves but
let me tell you something fingerless
gloves in this weather [ __ ]
um nobody will turn the heat up in this
goddamn state
well I bet you about the more people
like you realize the 20s and the tens
are coming right and I'm like no
I mean there's something below 30.
I love how you decided to move to the
east coast and the worst time to be in
the East Coast
I'm the anti-sno bird I'm a bird
yeah I hadn't thought about that uh I
got a movie theater and I gotta I gotta
make it work I got six months to make it
work uh really I have a lifetime but
making it work in the first six months
makes the rest of the lifetime easier
and stuff so I've devoted myself to
to being at smodcast Castle and making
it work
God bless you Kevin Smith you want to
come join me on New Year's Eve it'll
take me literally 12 seconds to get from
my apartment to the stage
now I'm just bringing it George Carlin
said this job would be great if everyone
would just come to my house and I always
thought that was like oh he's right and
now I've I've got that
get it yeah let me tell you something
they've been in the movie A filmmaker
living above a movie theater is like a
[ __ ] cobbler living in a giant shoe
it's just adorable
I mean I don't know why this wasn't the
premise for some sitcom back in like
1987. don't think it's not gonna be
marked
but apparently now's not the time to
pitch did you read that New York Times
article about the bloodbath that's going
on in development right now
with all the uh
explosion implosion whatever the [ __ ]
with everyone collapsing now uh the age
the Golden Era of streaming the Golden
Age of streaming they're saying has come
to an end because you know starting with
HBO Max going like [ __ ] this we're
getting rid of all this [ __ ] Netflix is
starting to follow suit uh I guess Hulu
to some degree they said the two of them
that haven't done it yet are Apple and
Amazon they're actually making more [ __ ]
uh but they're not beholden to the to
the Moors of the business because they
sell technology and toilet paper so
that's where their money comes from and
stuff but the entertainment industry
folks are
cinching the belts and and apparently
like nothing's getting made right now so
you go in you could you could be [ __ ]
you know JJ Abrams Jane James Cameron
pitching a thing and they're like I
don't know that sounds expensive so it
seems to be like a time not to even be
pitching though right yeah I mean it's
it's it's gonna be bad
for the next couple of months until
people do realize like Yeah we actually
have to make new shows like we have to
have some new things to put on on our
services be they linear TV terrestrial
TV cable broadcaster streaming but
I don't think anybody's writing big
checks for a while until the sort of
business shakes itself out and finds
level whatever that looks like which
basically looks like it's going to be TV
in the early 2000s again
which says Hey welcome to free ad
supported television you mean like
television yeah just like television
except now it's on an App instead of on
a channel on your dial which is the
worst version of television
[Music]
um in chat Chris Collins says super
excited about Amazon making a Stephen
King Dark Tower series is that true
um yeah Mike Flanagan the guy who had a
had done
um
um what'd you call it the whole Suite of
things doctor sleep and um oh God yeah
no a bunch of stuff on Netflix like
midnight mass
um
I wonder if they follow the House of
Usher but that might not be right
um but yeah like he's in business he's
in the Stephen King business and trying
to crack the uncrackable which is The
Dark Tower
um there have been a handful of versions
of goes at it there was the one that
became the weird kids Gunslinger movie
with Idris Elba and Matthew McConaughey
um Glenn Mazzara uh similarly for Amazon
was taking a run at it as a as a sort of
Maxi series
the the movies were supposed to be there
was a whole version whereas Ron Howard
was going to make like I'm gonna do a
movie and then a season of TV and then a
movie and then a season of TV and that
was going to be the way that story was
going to get told
um but that proved I think too ambitious
and a little too odd for an audience to
grasp and so that never happened and so
Mike Flanagan is making a go at it and
we'll see I wish him luck
I wish you luck he's very he's busy all
the time he's working okay yeah now he
he likes to work which is the the best
way to be if you're a creative person
God bless him you got up at a q a
in Vancouver I was up there for um I
think we were showing clerk that Malcolm
Ingram's documentary and he was the
first question he got up and he was like
um my name is Mike Flanagan I make I
make her films and TV shows I was like I
[ __ ] know who you are and he was he
said very kind things about me he's like
I met you years ago and you were like
super nice to me and like that always
meant something blah blah just that and
I was like well [ __ ] Mike this means
the world you're very successful now
[ __ ] hire me
but he didn't hire me
oh you just you just surely I don't just
I got a mortgage to pay my God damn it
now but I got a movie theater
um lovely dude
ever nothing but good things yeah
okay shall we talk about the big blue
cats bats
Let's do let's
big blue cats the big blue cats
um kids
me and Mark saw Avatar
I haven't not seen it twice
I don't mean this to sound
why
genuinely inquisitive
was there like you had to see it with
somebody else or precisely I went I went
opening night with uh with the fellas
and then I went again yesterday with uh
with my wife and back from college son
and so I've now devoted
six hours and 42 minutes to uh to The
Adventures of blue cats in space
um
I uh here's what here's what I know
about this movie kids
um James Cameron uh makes that first
Avatar movie years ago
and kind of uh pushes mocap forward uh
you know and I'm not saying he's the
only one I'm sure people like hey man
[ __ ] Gollum yes I understand but you
know making an entire movie full of
characters that are all mocap and [ __ ]
you know say what you will that's
groundbreaking
um
and it's all difficult like it takes
years
and then one day the dude's like
I'm gonna do it all again but now I'm
gonna Add Water
the hardest thing in the world to do
even like you go talk to Steven
Spielberg uh about the Fable men's and
then afterwards you go talk to them
about Jaws and they'll tell you like
making a movie with water is [ __ ]
almost killed my career
um making a movie with digital water
even harder because that water's not
real now I'm gonna I'm gonna give you an
example of a shot
there's a moment in this movie where
there's a human character
dragging a blue cat out of the water
it's not very spoilery just that's what
happens
the human character is a boy so you say
13. so he's not even tall like a real
man he's a boy
and the shot lasts maybe I don't know 12
20 seconds of him pulling this big blue
cat out of the water and
and uh as I was watching it I was like
all that [ __ ] shot like before they
get into the dialogue before they do
anything else just a wide establishing
of him pulling the Luke out of the water
like it's so incredibly unreal that
almost every element had to be [ __ ]
created or recreated with the exception
of the human shot because he's not
really lifting a giant blue cat out of
the water he's lifting a guy in a mocap
suit out of the water who is not nearly
proportionally the same size as the blue
cat he'll be replaced by
so because of that the difficulty level
of that shot
is inherently [ __ ] increased if
there's no water like it's hard enough
but then everything has to have a Sheen
of water on it and look realistic and
not fall into The Uncanny Valley
every shot in this movie is an
incredible special effect that when you
watch the credits took like [ __ ]
thousands of artisans
to figure out and complete and
it's it's spellbinding you almost can't
judge it like a [ __ ]
normal ass movie
um except that he is a very good
Storyteller you say what you will about
Jim Cameron he knows
satisfying storytelling beats as we've
seen time and time again
um in his movies you know there were
those here
I I just feel like they would have been
easier to
gather if it was a little
sure this is a three hour and 20 minute
movie is that what it was about that you
know I I almost feel like nobody wants
to give a specific how much plus three
hours was it like is it 3 15 317 320 is
just it's three hours and more
three hours plus and and yeah like
I I described it to somebody as every
James Cameron movie ever made in the
same movie
like by the time you get to the finale
you will have spent times with Space
Marines you'll have spent time on a
sinking boat you'll have spent time
under the water you've been in the abyss
you've been in Aliens you've been in
Titanic
um I mean the only one that you're kind
of missing is True Lies because there's
no weird striptease happening in the
middle of it the very first hundred
million dollar movie
100 million dollar budget movie was True
Lies so this is not unfamiliar territory
for James Cameron to be like
what's the thing cost I'm gonna spend
way more than that
um but to be fair
True Lies notwithstanding in the Avatar
movies
while he you know completes his vision
or brings his vision to life he also
pushes the medium
forward like technologically
um so like
you know there's the hey he's making a
movie and then there's the whole hey
he's pushing a medium forward but to do
so you know he's they spend it
an ungodly amount of money it was I
think I saw the budget was
464 million
um I've heard I've Heard lots of
different numbers but it would not
surprise me especially given that he
shot
I think two three and four back to back
and so and he's got apparently a nine
hour cut of the next Avatar movie that
he needs to render all the VFX for him
he's going to show it to Fox and be like
here's what it is I saw that story on
the internet and I I'm not saying like
they're lying I just can't imagine
that's [ __ ] true that he wants to
there's a nine hour cut
and he wants to finish the effects not
even temp effects finish them the way
they look in the movie and then decide
what to cut but I think it's
I'm I'm hoping
I what I what I heard and what I think
is probably true are the there's nine
more hours of movie
now what parts of it are going to be in
avatars three and four what parts are we
moving the the the the midpoint of I
don't think it's we're gonna cut nine
hours down to three hours and then we're
gonna go and we're gonna res everything
I think it's
this is the material for the next two
maybe three movies here's what we have
um but even still wanting to render all
of it and then start making edits to it
does seem
weird but hey that's expensive it's
expensive if you're a person who's made
billions of dollars for people you're
like it's what I want I've always wanted
to do this so I'm going to do it yeah
and you know if anyone's going to get
away with it that guy I'm sure
I mean for for me like I I remember
seeing the first Avatar and I've always
felt about James Cameron he's one of my
favorite filmmakers but I've always felt
like the more money he got to make his
movies the less
um
the less deep and insightful his
screenplays for those movies were they
become basic and I don't mean basic as a
pejorative I mean they become Elemental
right like Titanic's screenplays not the
screenplay that Terminator 2 was which
is not the screenplay that aliens was it
is just very it's a romance here these
two people who meet you know I'm not
even gonna say cute except cute and then
they're in the middle of chaos and then
they find each other and then one of
them dies because apparently you can't
put two people on a door
um but so like that script is not full
of finesse but it becomes Mythic it
becomes archetypal and Avatar continues
that by making it you know FernGully
Pocahontas on a distant planet with Blue
kittens it's here's the encroachment of
colonization here's the natural response
that said colonization and also a
romance in the middle of it a bit of
Romeo and Juliet and it's still very
like you can see all of the building
blocks of those stories and how they do
kind of just weld together and they have
a Mythic heft to it and so it works but
he's still an expert Craftsman he's an
expert director he knows how to do drama
and action
um and so I sort of felt less invested
in the story this time around because
now there's not even the tension of will
they fall in love or won't they it's we
are in love we have a family are we
going to lose one of these kids maybe
who knows but it's no longer the tension
of those two cultures colliding it's now
oh the colonization is back spoiler
alert
the movie The Gentle plot spoiler of the
movie is the sky people have returned to
Pandora to do the same thing they were
going to do before that that was the
honestly like the one thing Us in the
first like you know 10 20 minutes of the
movie right they do a kind of
you know previously on Avatar right and
and not so much of the movie but more of
what's been happening on Pandora since
and then all of a sudden they're like
but then the sky people came back and
I'm like you're kidding just we're gonna
do that again yeah I was like what this
is there a second death star is this
Return of the Jedi
somehow Palpatine returned but let's be
fair this time they didn't come back for
unobtainium they came back for something
else yes for a different thing that has
a name that is also the drippy gooey
heart of this movie
um people are like did you cry
um I did not but I got very close on the
space whales on the Pandora on the
Pandora Wales the navi whales whatever
they were called
um that that was pretty hard to watch
but uh the whole time I kept going like
it's just these are special effects yeah
like this is ultimately an animated
movie
um because the amount of actual
live-action photography I'd love to know
how much that was I don't think there's
a bunch I think it's we're on boats now
so the boats are real
um but everything else every other thing
with a blue kitten in it is a VFX every
time you're in the water there's no
water there
um every time you with an animal there's
no animal there
um it's remarkable like it is it is a
thing to behold and I saw it at the at
the TCL Chinese Cinema in IMAX 3D and
it's unbelievable like it is just so
immersive it is so tactile
um
but you know I saw it at smog Castle
Cinemas in Atlantic Highlands New Jersey
and uh we did not have a 3D screening
obviously and stuff but um normally I
watch stuff on my on my phone so I I was
that me watching on the on a regular on
a big screen that wasn't a 3D screen was
still an event for me yeah no it is it's
it's astonishing to look at and every
single cent of those 400 million dollars
is on the screen it's never like what
did they spend the money on just look at
it they're just
setting money on fire in order to
capture it and put it on the screen for
you it's it's remarkable but
you know it's a lot of movie there's
there's a there's a whole nature
documentary right in the middle of this
movie where there's no actual bad guy
threat it's just we're gonna swim with
some fish
um it all the money is there you can see
it like look at all the funnies look at
the money Roll by
um it's big it's a lot of movie
it's a lot of moving
um could have could have used
slightly less
yeah that movie could have been 245 and
you wouldn't have missed anything
but to be fair as I was watching it I
couldn't think of a single storyline to
drop so it would have been frame [ __ ]
it but there's a lot of frames to plop
them so there is but you know it's some
of the Story begins to get repetitive
after a while
which is
um you know to to give you a basic plot
of what this movie is without spoiling
very much of it
um in the intervening years between
Avatar one and Avatar Two
um Jake Sully
um who has a computer oh Jake Sully
music
a couple times in the movie I was like
yeah call back call back what Jake she's
wonderful man [ __ ] like honestly uh I
believe I know this for a fact Zoe
Saldana is a jersey uh person she comes
from Jersey just like No And they bury
her under effects and she's you could
still see her performance Sean and food
and she does misery so [ __ ] well man
yeah like I mean she's just like I just
letting it out oh she's fantastic and
then she goes into [ __ ] like
Terminator mode yeah there there's a lot
in this movie of like dudes being stoic
with grief and women screaming their
faces off with grief
to the point we're like
so
why
every now and again I was just why why
this why is this the standard grief
response to women versus men to you
James Cameron but
glancing past that it is now Jake and
and natiri have four children
um one of which is apparently the
Immaculate Conception of something with
Sigourney Weaver's character who just
give Shane Coleman who is our A.D on
clerks three he came to that kevitar
screening that we had and um it was uh
hey Mikey back there
can you plug this in my computer's about
to go
um he uh came in 10 minutes late and at
the end of the movie was just like I
hate to say this but I came in 10
minutes late
what happened like because they they
included a crucial amount of information
like 10 minutes it was a very like
hey man we're going to get you there
there's a lot to catch up on and here we
go and if you did come in late you were
kind of screwed a little bit you know
and so Jake and the TV have these four
kids
um the sky people have returned Jake is
now leading the Insurgency
um and then for for reasons they have to
abandon their their their home base
because
um an enemy from the past has returned
and is on a balls out quest to kill Jake
Sully and so Jake has to keep his family
safe our family is our Fortress uh
whatever and uh and so they leave the
forest and then they go to these sea
people and then they go over you know
Islands into the sea and then they find
um what apparently is New Zealand
um blue New Zealand
um filled with the people who make their
lives in the sea they got thicker Tails
they got webbed feet you know and
they've evolved to BC people and they
think that they'll be safe there until
the same guy who was chasing them
um from the Forest Finds them in the
water and so it becomes a literally a
fish out of water story about the the
Sully family learning to adapt to sea
life and meeting other kids and the
bullies and the I don't fit in and then
there's the two sons one of which is the
dutiful one of which is the bit of the
Rebel but he's understood dad you just
don't understand me Dad I'm a I'm an
outcast dad lots of things oh that's a
nice moment though at the end where is I
got to see you
yes it's a it's a long road to hoe to
get to what seemed to be I see you and
then out from nowhere she was like no
Jake's silly
she's so [ __ ] good man they keep
burying her in makeup like why won't
they let her be a human being in these
movies
um that is the next question any of
these questions it's all getting
what's the cat's name and that tiri the
name I look
there were so many blue cats and they
were real quick with the names so
and I know that the Sigourney Weaver
teenager was Kitty which I think is
k-i-d-i and not k-i-t-t-y
now that that
was one of the things Shane was lost
about he's like where'd that girl come
from I was like the way I understand it
she was an immaculately conceived child
from Sigourney Weaver's
blue cat no yes but her but she was
gorny Weaver died and was eaten by the
tree right right
but her blue cat body then had a baby
right I I mean look
guy could do what he wants he's a great
Storyteller but like yep that happens
before the movie
that seems compelling and dramatic
is that a mystery like what happened
here but
I mean the long con yeah much story to
tell that he could do that in a preamble
you know and I'm sure that will be the
mystery going forward as to now like who
who's who's her dad
um why does she seem to be like Forest
um Jedi where she's controlling the
animal world with her brain stem stuff
um and so it's it is both a big movie
about again colonization and and
environmentalism
um it is the it is the most like save
the whales movies in Star Trek 4.
um last movie was like save the trees
this one's like save the whales yeah
um you know
I haven't seen so much whale business in
Star Trek 4. and there was a harpoon
scene in that movie as well that also
involved like a spaceship yep yes it did
oh good poll everyone's talking in chat
that uh
um Zoe Saldana uh played Uhura and hura
as a human I'm like yes yes that's I
know she's been in things without makeup
it was a bit of the old funny
observation
if he throw away we try to be funny here
but I love getting fact checked thank
you yeah
um she's on our wall at the movie
theater you know in the lobby we got a
wall full of like famous people from New
Jersey and she's up there nice as Gamora
her Zoe Saldana which is how she's not
pronouncing it she don't pronounce it
that way right
um she she actually does she she
stretches she's got the tilde over the
end so it is Zoe Saldana is that right
yeah I have no idea man that's that's
awesome that's like Manana Manana
Saldana
um so yeah like there's there's a lot of
story there's a lot of look how awesome
this looks
um there's a lot of things that could
have been a conversation that weren't
that might have short-circuited some of
what might have felt like Teenage
um [ __ ] drama
um it's got nine different endings
um and all of which are endings to other
James Cameron movies like the boat's
rolling over get to the top of it
again I remember that from Titanic it's
like oh the water's coming in we got to
go from compartment to compartment so
yeah that's the bit from the abyss
uh okay all right I liked it then I like
it now
yeah it is kind of like a Jim's can Jim
Cameron's Greatest Hits thing he's like
I know how to do this yeah we did it
like this in the UPS except we were
actually underwater and that was bad so
now we're just on the volume which is
good
um
but yeah and I and I do like the the
lengths to which he goes especially from
a design perspective to build a world
you've never seen before like the Flora
and the fauna and even the ships and the
tech and all of it is also incredibly
bespoke and also like very imaginative
like you're living inside the dude's
imagination and you know most people
kind of like dismiss Jim Cameron as like
a you know oh he likes to make expensive
movies and he yells and I'm the king of
the world and [ __ ] like that but it's
like he must have an incredibly fertile
imagination like look at the stories
that he tells look at how colorful that
movie is he has to create every species
right yeah
I mean even before you film a frame he's
made an entire universe yeah like and
it's and it's all out of whole cloth
except for
um his his desire to strip mine cultures
for alien specificity
which is what are the new see people
like well they're just Maori but they're
now a lighter shade of green
you know down to the facial tattoos down
to the the the Haka poses down to like
we cast a a New Zealander to be the king
of this particular
tribe he played the queen that was Kate
Winslet which I didn't realize until the
movie was all over I saw her name in the
credits I was like oh yeah she was doing
press but who was she and then I was
like wait a second hold on was she
pregnant while they were making the
movie is that why he made her pregnant
um I don't I saw there were some behind
the scenes
um feature at the drop today about like
the actors giving it to character and
there was some shot of her
looking pregnant I don't know if that
was an application on the on the on the
suit or whether she was actually
pregnant and they made that part of the
movie
um
I don't know I don't know but it was
just like like dude like why not extend
that same level of rigor and invention
into the cultural specificity of the
navi as opposed to in the first one
making them sort of First Nations
um
sort of plains Forest Warriors like
Navajo or Cherokee
um and now you've made the the sea
people
um Maori and like
it's it's so one-to-one
that it's it it's a little like huh you
just kind of took what you wanted you
colonized the Maori for your movie and
took what you wanted and left the rest
um
and so that was the one part that kind
of rubbed me a little bit the wrong way
um like make an alien that's actually
alien like I understand you wanting to
mirror the the metaphorical story of
colonization I get it but like
and they have to do war cries do they
have to Yelp from the top of horseback
do they have to
all of these things that just feel
a little disingenuous
um but you know
it's it is so much moving you will find
something to like in it even if you
don't like all of it
um I heard that they come to Earth in
the last one
you're running out of places to go so I
get it that makes sense that might make
me stick around
Earth do they
get a ship now oh that's gotta [ __ ] with
Earth let's see what that happens
they go to Earth in the last one they'll
like give us back our unobtainium and
all the whale brain views
laughs
yeah and why poor uh Jermaine Clement
had to talk in his American accent with
Jane great
as well scientist
that was him yeah
yeah
oh my God this guy looks familiar but
like I didn't realize it was him wow
yeah
um seamless uh Roland hidden in his
performance like although he didn't have
the benefit of all that
Navi makeup now he just got to show up
on the day somebody asked in chat did I
make it through the entire time without
having to go to the bathroom yeah I got
a pretty good bladder I don't mean to
brag but pretty good very strong for an
older man pretty strong absolutely um
but no I I bought some snacks with me
and I settled in I brought all my snacks
from home and I told the audience like
the snacks at the movie theater
overpriced
I sat there and ate my own snacks but uh
did not check out to go to the bathroom
stayed the whole time I saw every damn
second
yeah I mean I did as well although
there's a hundred percent times I could
have gotten up and left and come back
and not missed much
it's like are they still swimming okay
when they were all like um Blues
[Laughter]
um well Lord knows he's a better
filmmaker than uh uh any of us will ever
be
um and uh somebody said like you know
the the world he created looked
imaginative but the screenplay was not
well that's why I didn't say that the
screenplay was imaginative I said we
live in his imagination all the colorful
characters he just create every
character and stuff he's a World Builder
now yep
uh yes and it's an astonishing world
what do you think do you think it
reaches the the story is it has to make
two billion to break even
um well I mean it's it's
it is currently at let me see
134 million dollars was its opening
weekend
um it's now at 301 million Global after
week one
um
yeah it's made 301 million dollars
International after the first weekend so
they're up to half a billion already
almost almost I mean Global includes the
the domestic as well
um
I think they're up to 464.
yeah
it could be between the U.S and overseas
it was close to close to half a billion
uh a strong start but not a start that
indicates they'll get to 2 billion
however never bet against Jim Cameron
his movies like you know Titanic did not
open and light the world on fire it did
like 20 25 million but then every week
it kept doing 20 million 20 million and
what they said about uh Avatar 2 is
um it's not front loaded with pre-sales
like a Marvel movie so when a Marvel
movie comes out the pre-sales all happen
like you know in the first weekend
everybody needs to see it uh avatars are
spread out over the next few weeks and
there's no competition for this movie
nothing comes close to what it is so the
you know it there's there's a racism
like he may actually pull this one off
you know I mean it's it's
there are also more
because part of what Avatar the first
avatar did was
popularized 3D in cinemas like that was
the reason why anybody converted their
theater into having a 3D screen is
because they wanted Avatar and so an
Avatar 2 similarly plays incredibly well
in 3D there are fewer of those screens
that cost more to attend and so people
will if they're going to revisit it they
will revisit those screens in the second
go around if they didn't see it in the
first go round
I think it plays more than like Maverick
played than like
Doctor Strange played which is an older
audience is going to be coming to this
over a longer amount of time like that
it will hold better than your average
just we came out of the gate hard
Blockbuster
um it doesn't get to 2 billion I don't
know like you need to be a phenomenon to
get to 2 billion and I don't know if
this is a phenomenon yet
um someone in chat corrected me and said
it needs uh boat Trek says it needs 1.2
billion so that's 800 million less than
2 billion and they're almost at the
halfway mark already yeah no there's
there's a chance that it'll get there
you know if not a lock but definitely a
chance
you know there there are still like
we're not quite at full pre-pandemic
um numbers of attendance to movies but
we're getting there for certain movies
um we're probably 90 where we were and
so
it's got a good shot it's got a good
shot and to your point there's nothing
that big going up against it there's
there's smart counter programming but
there's not some direct giant
Blockbuster in the offing
um I think even until like February
um well uh you know
go see it kids
yeah
if you're you're into that sort of thing
yeah I mean the next Real movie that
could chip away at it is quantumania
which is what February February 17th
um did you hear in all that James Gunn
stuff that James say that
they very interested in Ben Affleck
directing something for this yeah new DC
Studios yeah I mean
my boy my boy's Wicked smart
Wicked smart my boys he could totally
drag the [ __ ] out of one of them
pictures man I mean he almost directed a
Batman movie got very close to it
yeah
yeah it's true
um all right do we have anything else to
say about everyone's saying my mic is
low I don't have a mic I'm using the
same [ __ ] mic I always use which is
the laptop mic mark
overachiever of the week has a brand new
microphone so you're getting a rich
silky smooth sounds of Mark Bernard's
voice me you're dealing with an open
space store normally I'm in a closed
environment but for those who came in
late
actual comic book damn store kids wear
them up load them up
James I'm Bob secret stash located in
Red Bank New Jersey did I show you my
comic book no show me your comic book
uh this is one with the exclusive secret
stash cover by Andrew Thomas there's uh
Holden McNeil AKA Ben Affleck wearing
Jay Smock from Jane sound box straight
back what's going on in this story
buy it and find out
this is an exclusive cover from
Michael Allred man from Things From
Another World
[Music]
from Jeff Quigley for quick stops number
two the stash exclusive cover and
this is
Phil Hester's
amazing cover oh I love Phil Randall
holding Brody
um then of course there's masquerade
look at this [ __ ] that [ __ ] look at
that cupboards God damn it that's
beautiful
um
and this one
from Captain ribman as well uh kev's
Comics kids secret stash press published
by Dark Horse masquerade now in stores
quick stops downstairs I think
masquerade number four comes out pretty
soon quick stops number three comes out
in a couple weeks
Iceland well done Comics uh Batman obaf
man bamf
why hello bam bam I believe we've
reached the show where you are our
conduit to the audience although I've
been reading chat this whole time
um
what does the audience want to know what
questions will we be answering I've got
a few hey I'll shout out though
um when we started doing podcasts 11
almost 12 years ago
uh there was uh a guy named Justin Yates
and a guy named Joey Harris who shot
podcasts and uh when we were at the
Lovitz
and Justin was the lead
assistant editor on Avatar 2. and Joey
was worked in the visual effects
Department as well so we have two
smod alums with their names up in the
credits of that movie in pretty decent
positions
I got uh someone else in that world too
my kid's godmother Lisa Romaine she
worked on the first Avatar and then she
spent the last few years working I think
on the second one she in the first
avatar she was Sigourney Weaver's
blue cat body
no caps for all the Sigourney stuff and
I don't know what she did on this one
but like she's been I remember when she
was making the movie she was trying to
explain it like years before it came out
and she was just like I wear it like a
lot of dots all over my outfit and I I'm
meant to be a giant cat and I was like
oh I'm sure that's gonna make a lot of
money yeah right
uh but yeah so she is she gave me some
inside dope on the shooting of those
flicks and my God it's just it's a
different kind of filming it's so weird
to be like I'm a filmmaker too not
really not like that I mean it's it's
performance capture is such a weird
Beast because you're not doing shots
there's no shot selection on the day
like you're literally getting the
performance you're not concerned about
cameras you're not concerned about
lenses you're not concerned about
lighting none of it it's just all
performance and all of the shot
selection comes after the fact
so it's like yeah we want you walking
and jumping and moving and all that
stuff but it is not about close wide to
over none of that and that is just such
a different way to think about it when
um when the first avatar came out uh the
job I was at we interviewed Sigourney
Weaver who was wonderful
and uh she was sitting around waiting
for her next interview to start and so
we were talking
and I asked her because at the time
there was a lot of people talking about
how they hated acting against Green
Screen and how they could it's not
really acting
so I asked Sigourney Weaver uh who at
that time was already a Hall of Fame
actress
15 years ago she said she loved it and
she said she loved it because working on
Avatar she was able to
do the scene one time and didn't have to
repeat the performance to change camera
angles 12 times like they do on a
regular movie so she said every
performance I gave they captured every
angle so every take
I gave I I got to play I tweaked it I
went this way I went that way I went up
I went down and that she loved it
because she just got to make pretend
every day
and they she never had to repeat the
same performance over and over which I
thought was a really cool way to think
about it that is cool I hadn't thought
about it yeah I mean it's like theater
that way where it's you're not I mean
there are takes that you're doing for
performance but you're not stopping to
to we got to move the lights around
they're not stopping for any of it just
all right let's go again let's go again
let's go again
uh in chat Mark James Zapp Zepp is
asking can we talk about the Dr Seuss
cuck chair in Mark's background
[Laughter]
something I'm not familiar with I I you
know I don't hey whatever that dude
wants to think Dr Seuss does in his off
time
between him and it's not even Dr Seuss
is it a Pixar aren't you yeah it's it's
up
sure is yeah this is Carl and Ellie's
living room
uh just like one of our sponsors
Bluetooth ladies and gentlemen indeed
up
keep it up
um okay okay uh first question they're
asking us about the Oppenheimer trailer
have you watched it I did I've seen two
versions of it I saw the IMAX exclusive
trailer that they showed before Avatar
um and also the [ __ ] the the dead
reckoning trailer for Mission Impossible
whatever that is or Tom Cruise drives
himself off a cliff on a motorcycle
the whole trailer is just look at its
Snake Canyon all over again it's Evil
Knievel type [ __ ] it's we built this
ramp off this cliff in Norway that I'm
gonna ride a motorcycle off the edge of
and let's show you how we built it let's
show you they run up to it and then
you're gonna see me Tom Cruise do this
[ __ ] thing it's
I people [ __ ] cheered in the theater
for him driving a motorcycle off a cliff
that's what he does now like he's like
yeah but I also endangered my life
um I haven't seen the Barbie trailer
either did you see the Barbie trailer I
did it's there's not much of a trailer
to it it's more like 2001
um it's very much you know
stealing the dawn of man sequence but
with a old [ __ ] child's doll and then
the Obelisk is a Barbie doll
um
so it's cool but it's not much trailer
to it Oppenheimer is so odd to me
because it's a [ __ ] July movie about
a guy who's made in July
it's July 23rd 23 I think is Oppenheimer
it's not like coming out this year no
it's a it's a giant summer blockbuster
about a bunch of scientists who will
probably set off a bomb by the end of it
that is that's some James Cameron
James Cameron like let's just make
let's go against the grain what are they
like in the summer fun movies wait let's
make a movie about the nuclear bomb the
atomic bomb yes it is the live broadcast
uh let me ask you a question this movie
in black and white no
color color although there are some
black and white at least according to
the trailer some sequences that are in
black and white but it's very colory
well I'm gonna see if it's a black and
white I don't like black and white
movies
Fair says the guy who made Clerks
um all right
Banff man listen to it
um
just made an excellent observation shot
he says Cruz is Jackie Chan now it's
true true a big part of his cell is like
I'm gonna do it man I'm gonna die man
yeah except Jackie Chan wouldn't like
that wasn't part of the cell of the
movie it was
after the movie was over look at all the
ways I almost died giving you this movie
the closing credits were always that
Montage of Jackie's almost killing
himself
that's true Jackie limped so Tom Cruise
can run
and run very fast as We Know
all right back to you okay
[Music]
uh Rob McFarland wants to know
his Spider-Man's amazing uh if you knew
it was going to be the best work you
ever did would you rather direct and
write a Star Wars film or a Batman film
[Music]
wait that's the first part again
you you you were told you know your
Clairvoyant this will be the best
project you've ever done
Star Wars or Batman
what do you choose to do well it's a
guaranteed hit either way
yes so really it's just about what makes
me happy or what I what would my
preference be God these are JJ Abrams
levels it's like your your legacy do you
want your legacy to be Batman the best
Batman or the best uh Star Wars
be honest no matter what I make my
legacy is he made clerks didn't he
that's the clerk's guy so it don't
matter what I do with this late in the
game
Clerk's guy going to be in my Epitaph
and I'm fine with that
um but in this fantasy world I'll play
along
I would prefer it to be a Batman film
over Star Wars film I think uh while
Star Wars of course was a big part of my
childhood and I've referenced it
throughout all the movies and you know I
was Big Star Wars
fan that just always seemed
you know it's got robots
[ __ ] ships
again Wookies it just seems complex now
Batman that's just a guy in a fun suit
uh and a mask and then you know the bad
guys could be a little wild but I would
keep that [ __ ] real
so he wouldn't be fighting
you know
like apocalypse or or Doomsday or
anything like that he'd be fighting
Mr Freeze and playfuls
I wouldn't I couldn't do those guys I
would want to do Mr Freeze but that
seems like an expensive movie
um so I would probably
I mean they just did the Riddler so you
know I don't I don't have to come up
with my villain that wasn't the question
right no
I choose Batman I think it would mean
as much as I love Star Wars I I think
I'm more of a I could pull off a Batman
if you watch you know a lot of people
like you can't pull off [ __ ] including
your shirt when you have sex you're
absolutely right I leave it on
that kind of cuck that being said
um I uh I I think I would
I think
if you ever saw a red state
motion picture I made a few years ago
this is you know well shot action
especially for a low budget four million
I I think I would uh get Dave Klein Who
currently shoots like every Star Wars
thing there is
my DP from clerks and Mallrats Chase
gaming but also from Red State and make
a real like [ __ ] hardcore action
Batman movie where you could see every
punch
none of this like frame rate [ __ ] like
just
just wides of Batman beating ass like
remember remember Zack Snyder's entire
Batman sequence in Batman v Superman he
explodes into the room and like whips
the crate and oh my God like that wow
you saw all the punches
you know I'm not I'm not [ __ ] on
Nolan I love Chris Nolan's Batman but
like I just watched Batman Begins fairly
recently like good luck seeing a punch
get thrown now the camera's like right
in there and doing this [ __ ] and whatnot
whereas like Zack Snyder is like I'm
gonna live in a wide and one and you
know let you see let you show you all
the things he does in the video games
I thought that was cool
um but I wouldn't that wouldn't be my
Batman I'll tell you that much because
that's that seems like a lot of work my
Batman be more like the detective
sitting around talking Batman there'd be
a lot of rooftop conversations
and a lot of those they would be like
why do you think they all act this way
is it you or like you're not here do
they still dress up and do naughty like
what was that all about why are they
doing crimes Batman
I didn't go to school for this I don't
know
I'm self-taught
uh what about you
um
I think first I will reject the premise
of the question and say that if I know
that I can make the best movie that I'm
ever going to do then I'm gonna make my
own new thing and not somebody else's
thing
but
um to to
Buckle under the pressure of the
question I think I go Star Wars and not
Batman
I think there's more upside to Star Wars
oof I don't I don't know who has it
worse I don't know who's going to be mad
at more angry at you DC fans or Star
Wars fans
um yeah you know probably Star Wars fans
um you know this works that's the
premise like it's full whatever it is
it's going to be great it's according to
the premise through hell to get there
but at the end of the day it's [ __ ]
everything right
um I just think that that and or
notwithstanding I think feature wise if
I'm making a movie I think there have
been more bad Star Wars movies than
there have been good Star Wars movies
and so I think that there's more upshot
to make a good Star Wars movie to make
the thing that people will remember as
they return to form as opposed to oh
well you know it's it's it's good like
The Dark Knight is good or it's good
like Batman Begins is good or it's good
like the OG Batman is good or it's good
like the Batman is good
um
I think I think there's more there's
more room to Dazzle in Star Wars and
there's so much more story to tell that
nobody's told there's a universe in Star
Wars where there's a guy in Batman
um so I think there's just there's
there's so many more ways to go
um yes but
[ __ ] Batman
[Laughter]
um I'm going to dig up one of my
favorite old tweets
and no it's not the you know my wife
owns my book tweet
everyone hates on the internet
um this is a tweet about Batman
and it started from February 12th
it started from uh read the dispossessed
by Ursula K Laguna or Joshua P something
Tech uh tweeted growing up is realizing
Batman could have done way more to solve
crime in Gotham by giving everyone food
and shelter than he did by beating the
crap out of people
and then Patrick Willems Patrick H
Williams tweeted yes this is definitely
the solution to when an evil clown
poisons the water supply
one of the most brilliant tweets ever
written except his follow-up was even
better is fire he writes this is the
world's most boring take read a comic
book Bruce Wayne funds all those
programs but then also sometimes kg
Beast is going on a murdering spree and
low-income housing won't solve that
brilliant give that guy a Batman movie
that's how you need to think about the
Batman
um
Victor Garber would be my uh Jim Jim uh
Jim uh Gordon by the way nice good but
then he'd finally have to deal with me
I did this just to get to talk to Victor
Garber I'd be like I need garbage like
he's passing I was like offer him 20
million dollars I will win this battle
um
um all right Banff man get us someplace
else
uh okay
um if uh this is
let's see look it's kulak uh wants to
know if you were to make a the Fable
men's for yourself
what would be some of the standout
points in the film about your life and
how you got here
I I just did make the Fable men's issue
it's what I've been doing for 30 years
way better but yeah same idea of like
I'm gonna [ __ ] Tiptoe Through the
Tulips of my past and how I got here but
uh yeah
um I don't know I mean to be fair the 4
30 movie is not about a kid who wants to
be a Movie Maker but about my young life
which was just watching movies
um so I guess there's a little bit in
there not much though fablemans is a
wonderful movie still
stays with me and the line in the movie
where
they say you can't just love something
you have to take care of it
it's [ __ ] like one of the most
powerful things I've ever heard in my
life 52 years I've never heard that
expression before I thought that was
absolutely wonderful but that closing
scene with John Ford is pure movie Magic
and the final shot is probably my
favorite final shot of of any film
including mine I love the closing shot
of Clerks three but my God his closing
shot with a frame readjust the Horizon
on the bottom is
breathtakingly beautiful
um but uh anyway yeah I mean clerk three
is kind of my fable man so it'd be weird
to do it again
um what about you I don't know like I I
have not been that introspective about
my path nor do I think that it is as
studied with stars and wonder and
glorious Spielberg's was being you know
able to hop over a fence and be on a lot
and stumble into famous people doing
cool [ __ ]
um
although honestly the thing that that
most recently would be in the movie
is I don't know if you if you hopped
upon this on the Instagram about a week
or two ago
um
your friend in mind Ming Chen was
producing a podcast
um where somebody in his Network whose
Name Escapes me at the moment was
interviewing Corey Glover
from uh Living Color
and Corey Glover mentioned that one of
his favorite podcasts was fat man beyond
um and like he's like it's my favorite
podcast I listen to that every time it's
out it's like I [ __ ] with both of those
guys heavy and and so I put it up on
Twitter uh no Instagram and and
basically it was Living Color was for me
when I was growing up a seminal
experience because I did not encounter
various interpretations of what it's
like to be a black person in the media
at that time in like 1986 1987 you were
either Prince Michael Jackson or every
other rapper
but Living Color was the thing that gave
me license to be a little weird to get
in touch with all of the various parts
of me that I had to a certain degree
been subsuming like like rock and roll I
like guitars I like drums I like I like
I like classical music I like rap I like
all of it and Living Color being on TV
was was a big reason for that
and so Corey Glover reached out it's
like yo what's your phone number
I was like what it's like yeah what's
your phone number we need to have a
conversation oh my God you joined the
cult of personality a hundred percent I
joined a couple personality and we
talked for like an hour the day after as
he was driving from some place like
Brooklyn New Jersey or whatever it is
and we're just two nerds talking about
the stuff that we love and I told him
he's like man I have to I have to tell
you in person the things I put on the
internet how much Living Color meant to
me how much you guys meant to me is like
it's a con it's a Continuum man it's
like you know we meant to you what you
know James Brown meant to me what and
I'm like yeah that's what LeVar Burton
meant to me and somebody meant that for
LeVar Burton there is always a a
Continuum of people being inspired by
other people to find out who they're
supposed to be
um and so if I had to have a movie
fableman style about my life that would
be part of it that feeling of connecting
with a person who influenced you
who you discover later on in life some
25 years later that you are in turn
influencing them
that was kind of wonderful that is
that's beautiful that belongs in the
movie you got a scene I'm putting it in
the movie well the whole movie around
that
coming in chat said uh let me find it it
was cute they were like uh
um
marks
movie
uh
I can't find it but it said Mark's movie
ends with meeting Kev
that's the [ __ ] beginning of Martin
that's where it starts that's that's
Kevin inviting me to his house to watch
Zack and Miri
is that is that is that
beginning uh it's not quite the
beginning but it was the first like hey
man you're in La you should come and see
the movie
and so I came to your house and you're
like all right watch the movie and then
you left the room
and you left me in the library to watch
the movie and then you came back with a
pizza and then we hung out for like
seven hours
it was adorable it was
you know it's that was after playing
poker
that was after the the poker years
but they're like yeah just come and hang
out little did we know that one day we'd
be doing this I know like every week for
a decade all the time hell yeah all
right Bam Bam [ __ ]
we the question three you could make
that movie also Mark and frame it around
the conversation you have with him in
the car meaning like that's the device
to get you through the entire movie and
you can always bounce in it right just
talking to Corey
[Music]
um
hey sweet man is it cool when you find
out like somebody you liked likes you
it's like high school all over again
like wait what you like me like me
because I like you
like we have we had a very similar kind
of stumble across one another meet cute
and uh it's it you know it was it's
fun when it's just like oh you're an
artist I'm an artist and it's like dogs
you sniff each other's asses back
[Laughter]
way hotter version of Mark's scene that
I just wrote kids he's just sniffing
asses
um all right take us home
okay what we got
um my headphones just gave out so that's
super weird if everybody's looking at me
like what's going on
um
chat is saying um
uh my dancing uh makes it look like I
have to pee I don't but I'm standing I'm
glad I do the show in my chair
um but I could get a full swag going on
because I'm walking around look at this
[ __ ] I'm going downstairs
laughs
thank you
uh back to you Jesse what do they want
to know okay uh let's see last question
is from
polar Strat wants to know if you could
make a Christmas movie with Santa who
would you get to play Santa and what
kind of Santa would they be
Victor Garber would be myself
and he would be the most generous giving
Santa there ever was he would give me an
interview for my podcast
um no let's see you know what why would
I reward a guy who doesn't want the time
of day for me so no it won't be Victor
Garber I'm changing my mind wow yeah
that's right now I'm James Gunn I'm
canceling [ __ ]
look at me kids no
well that's not making fun of James Gunn
I love James Gunn I don't want anybody
writing an article going Smith questions
James Gunn
never
after guarding the Galaxy I would never
question James Gunn I'd be like
bro you know what you're doing
you know what you're doing uh all right
who do I want as my Santa
John Goodman
good pull yeah goody as Santa come on
I'm sure he's done it somewhere I know
he's done it on SNL I'm sure
that's my answer I'm sticking with it
what about you
um
[Music]
take away TD
I feel like taika as a sprightly old elf
I mean you put him in a fat suit clearly
um but there is there is a mischievous
nature to that particular Santa
um especially if it's a early in Santa's
career Santa
um pre like bowl full of jelly but like
a guy who's figuring out how to deliver
presents to everybody
I think that's kind of fun
um people suggesting Ben Affleck look
I'll cast Ben Affleck in anything
oh Kevin yeah yeah we have some late
breaking news what
um according to the Hollywood Reporter
officially Black Adam 2 is not moving
forward as part of DC's first chapter
um that's news I thought we all knew
that I guess it was conjecture up to
this point now it's official now it's
official Dwayne Johnson released in a
statement James Gunner not connected and
Black Adam will not be in their first
chapter of Storytelling however DC in
seven bucks is production company have
agreed to continue exploring the most
valuable ways Black Adam can be utilized
in future DC Multiverse chapters
foreign
wow
yeah amen remind me that if James Gunn
calls me I'm not answering the phone
probably not great news
uh wow man and but you know they're all
coming out of it not like pissed
they're not like going like and I hate
all these people like his sounds a lot
like Henry's statement too and as if I
know him Henry cavill's statement where
he's just like well they got a plan and
I'm not part of it and I get it
um James and I have known each other for
years and have always rooted for each
other to succeed Johnson wrote it's no
different now and I will always I will
always wrote vote for DC and Marvel to
win and win big
um you know basically it is a I'm
disappointed but I'm being political
about it and covering my ass a little
bit and hopefully something will come
forward but who knows when
um
if John Goodman was a good Santa on
Futurama is that was that from you Mike
John Goodman was a Santa on Futurama I I
can't believe nobody in chat line
they took a comic book man to tell me
that
come over and show him your [ __ ] face
comic book man people
kids do you remember a few years ago
when Comic Book Men was on AMC want a
little taste a little Susan what that
was like
is what happens kid when they take you
off of the uh
you get old you live under bridges
two of the five Comic Book Men wow gotta
collect them all that's true that's what
you get when you watch fat man beyond
um
well
our chat is lighting up with a bunch of
people telling us who should play
Santa and Ethan simply is the clear
winner
Jack Santa yeah they want a jacked Santa
let me tell you something I you know I
between uh the last time we did the show
and I think this time maybe I ended the
tour no I did the show last week I was
done already every night on the tour of
the J on the clerks through the
convenience Tour all 52 [ __ ] shows
whenever the offensively came up on
screen [ __ ] place went nuts like
legit
with the applauding and the [ __ ]
screaming and [ __ ] like that I'm telling
you if I about any brains whatsoever
my next movie would be a buddy cop movie
starring Ethan Supply
and Danny Trejo because he came up on
screen the audience but even more nuts
like you know after I would come up they
go nuts those two guys they were like I
know tearing seats to them and they love
those two cats so all the people in chat
they got a point man [ __ ] cats please a
jack Santa Claus plus he's one of the
sweetest people on the planet Ethan is
such a nice kid yeah
[Music]
Jack Santa and Danny Trejo as his elf
as his head elf
I like it or Danny Trejo is the bad guy
I guess that's not a good look
I mean you could do heat miser Cold
Miser
I just [ __ ] involuntarily [ __ ]
oh my God you're right you could want to
eat which one
I mean Danny Trejo I'm not gonna do the
voice but I'm gonna sing the song I'm Mr
Heat Miser that's not the way Danny
would do it no no not at all but also
that [ __ ] number would be a banger
like
that's a that's a [ __ ] Spotify hit if
ever there was one Billboard top 100
Heat Miser
um right Bad Bunny
ah there it is finally winged Blitzer
jumped in to say John Goodman played the
voice of Santa bot in season two of
Futurama
a comic book man beats you to that
winged Blitzer
a great name
um
or any Benny Williams in chat says Danny
Trejo as Santa's head elf but it's
literally just machete Santa is
kidnapped by the cartel written and
directed by Robert Rodriguez I'm in all
right yeah Danny Trejo is the elf who
administers the the naughty list
I heard it was super fun I hear it's
very good I might be watching it tonight
but uh me and Josh Roush gonna hook up
uh Indiana Jones and the kingdom of the
Crystal Skull
on purpose and everything
about it
yes yes by choice
um we had a conversation about it and
you know I was like you know what man
I'm gonna revisit that
because I watched the opening scene and
it was
it was good times
but I'm gonna give it another roll
because the [ __ ] trailer for
James mangold's Indiana Jones dial of
Destinies wonderful
he's riding a horse in a Subway what the
[ __ ]
um so you know I'm gonna [ __ ] with some
some mid Indiana Jones Indiana Jones
my opinion has changed
um
that's that's kind of the that's the
evening
Kenny turned me around on
Crystal Skull
I I look forward to the results of this
experiment
it's [ __ ] Uber Sprite said you better
be high you better believe it
every time a mutt shows up I'm gonna see
those crystal skulls the way they're
meant to be seen
um
kids clean shaven thanks to the good
folks of manscaped
uh Kamari Christie and chat said rest in
peace Kevin Smith still alive kids still
here healthiest I've ever been
um
literally at my [ __ ] adult dentist I
weigh 190 pounds good for you
try and stay alive
um for some reason a lot of people feel
that means like I'm sick it's quite the
opposite I was I could have used the
condolences when I was
heavier because I was technically sick
at that point but now
doing quite well thank you uh still
alive no need for me to rest in peace uh
but thank you for
the well wishes I mean unless it's a nap
in which case like Yeah by all means
yeah or if it's a holiday themed sleep
in Heavenly peace
sleep in Heavenly peace then I'll take
that a rest in peace
not yet still got [ __ ] to do miles to go
before I sleep kids the woods are
beautiful dark and deep but I promise
you have to keep miles to go
I thought JC was like if we can make
this like a not overly long one it'd be
great
just literally we're just Peter Jackson
in the end of this quote Robert Frost
and [ __ ] like this being a real off
topic
so yeah like 19 things to do
Advanced man does have some [ __ ] to do
man so we gotta go um Liam Doherty says
we missed the tubby guy in an Overcoat
uh
you might you almost didn't have them
that was part of the problem remember uh
you almost died so
this one is you know he's got longer
shelf life at least that's what his
cardiologist says so
I'm gonna I'm gonna stay here for a
minute
uh Advanced man
uh
without you
we got nothing we love you bam man oh
yes we do
go to it go to it now it is called the
scum and villainy cantina it is in
Hollywood on Hollywood Boulevard not to
be confused with Jay and Silent Bob's
secret stash which is where I am JC owns
a legit Watering Hole a nerd Watering
Hole where you won't get beat up
drinking you only get beat up if you're
like
on shot first or whatever [ __ ]
readership whatever the [ __ ] that old
argument uh go check it out do you want
to tell these kids anything before we
get out of here Batman uh tonight
tomorrow night and Thursday night I'm
hosting trivia and
pre-festivities for home alone at the
Walt Disney Concert Hall so apparently
somebody didn't get the memo that I
shouldn't be there uh oh man what a
bougie event you're going to so yeah uh
I've uh I've written
30 holiday trivia questions
so show up again
if we ask you for a sample then you'll
only have 29 but can we have a sample
yeah what um
what is the name of the pizza restaurant
they order from in Home Alone
wow [ __ ]
that's deep Cuts I want to say Pizza
Planet just to make a Pixar weapon
McCluskey's
uh little neros
yeah I would not uh farewell at this con
contest
um when is that event happening
uh about four hours from now can they
buy tickets for it or no the expensive
tickets I think there are single seat
expensive tickets left
fair enough there you go kids if you're
in the LA area and you want to see Banff
Man live
with single seat expensive tickets worst
selling history
buy yourself a Hanukkah present
that's true but Pope Paul 42 says Disney
adult gross
um Disney people don't like adults who
like Disney is that the
is that a thing on the internet I mean I
don't know I we're doing home alone
which was a fox movie back when it came
out just happens to be at the Disney
Concert yeah yeah which is also I
believe where Iron Man
part of Iron Man takes place there yeah
oh sorry man that's where that's where
Jeff Bridges like tells him that he
wanted him out that he got him out of
the company and [ __ ]
yeah and that's right
he's like I'll get a martini with with
olives lots of Olives like when they
when they get close to
and while they're dancing and [ __ ] and
she's like I'm wearing this ridiculous
dress and it's such a sweet scene
they're two really good actors man you
can watch you know what I watched
a senior Robert Downey Jr's document oh
did you like it
[ __ ] loved it after what you talked
about me and Josh rolled it the other
day I mean look I'll watch that dude do
anything but clearly he had a lot of
infection a lot of love and respect and
admiration for his for his father like
it's it's just it's wonderful
um
but [ __ ] I wish they would give him a
like a [ __ ] TV show I'd watch him
every week just saying [ __ ] he's such a
good pocket
um I I liked it you know it's it's
emotional a bunch of people like you can
cry I don't know if I cry but I did
absolutely love it
anyway sorry anyway uh senior
is on Netflix right now
um kids
what can I tell you other than
what are you doing New Year's Eve
welcome to New Jersey come to smod
Castle Cinemas and spend a New Year's
evening with Kevin Smith 10 o'clock
until [ __ ] 12 15 12 15 I'm kicking
everybody up uh tickets at smod
castlecinemas.com ladies and gentlemen
come on out for New Year's Eve Mark well
you got anything you got to sell not a
blessed thing my friend all I all I want
to sell is some holiday cheer over that
[ __ ] that's free you ain't even got to
sell that don't even gotta sell it I
just hope everybody out there has a safe
and happy holidays some people in uh
chat want to know if you're gonna bring
a splinter in March but we'll know more
about that down the road possibly it's
it I won't rule it out that's for
certain we got we got a DCP press of it
so it's ready to rumble he knows a guy
man he knows again
um
there it is kids uh without uh that guy
over there you got no [ __ ] stuff live
it up for the great Mark Bernard no
thank you Kevin Smith
um somebody asked did I move Mark day
said did Kevin move to New Jersey seems
to be there a lot now I am here for a
bunch of time with the opening of the
theater and whatnot
um but no I haven't moved out of
California uh I was just there we just
did a golden calves dinner at the house
on the 9th
um which if you're a member of that
Kevin Smith Club go to that Kevin
smithclub.com
uh those videos are already up and stuff
but uh no it's just you know my kids old
and grown up not old I mean [ __ ] I don't
want her to hear that yeah come on 23
she got her own house and you know when
she was young I spent every minute in
California that's where we lived but uh
now there's a lot more flexibility I
don't have to be you know boom all the
time because our kids got to go to
school or some sort of [ __ ] so
um you know here we are trying to build
the movie theater
um so that's that's where I took the
time
but uh kids
a thank you for spending this holiday
edition
this holiday edition
of
Batman Beyond with us man
uh
I want everyone to have a Merry
Christmas a happy Hanukkah
Happy Kwanzaa happy holidays across the
boards kids this is that time of year uh
where we all get to live like it's the
last 10 minutes of Scrooged
what better way to be I mean you could
try living that way all year long that's
what I do but at least during Christmas
here it is this is the you get an old
blanket go up to somebody and say oh by
the way here
that's part of his
uh there it is it's uh early ass look
we're done so early you got a whole
night ahead of you man
if you're on the East Coast go see a
movie oh we're closed tomorrow go see a
movie
um but there it is happy holidays from
all of us here
from the great beyond
fat man
Beyond and that's
fat man beyond for this week kids uh
tune in next week uh or when we do it
between the holidays which will probably
be next week for Batman Beyond I'm Kevin
Smith and I'm Mark Bernard tune in next
time same that time same fat channels
smodcast.com or youtube.com Kevin Smith
of Mary Jeff's kiss everybody
wow
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]